uh welcome back everybody to the
afternoon session so we have a sequence
of two talks followed by a reception
um
it's a pleasure to introduce jason lee
who's a professor at princeton
university and he's going to be talking
about uh you know
offline reinforcement learning all right
thanks costas
uh yeah so today i'll talk about some
work we did recently on offline ro
this is work with my student one hull uh
an undergraduate intern baiku and audrey
is stu at uiuc and a collaborator nan
jung
so okay the usual boilerplate rl
successful blah blah blah
okay what is an mdp
uh let me just skip ahead
uh what you have is an agent
uh it's essentially a collection of
bandits indexed by the state
then my hamster he chooses an action he
can go
up down left right or sleep
uh you know he wants he likes to sleep
but he wants to get to the peanut butter
also
uh then he's navigating this maze and
eventually he'll get the peanut butter
and then he's really happy and then
but he can also just choose the rest
once in a while maybe he's slightly
happy
okay so basically he follows a policy
which is a function
indexed by the state and then that uses
an action
and then he sees a reward and then he
moves
okay
this is just some standard
the value of a policy is basically if
you run the policy how much reward you
get
and the queue function tells you
essentially
uh
if you take an action and then run a
policy what is your reward
and all of these expectations are under
the policy and then i'll work in the
discounted rl setting so everything here
is standard
so a slight distinction
in this talk i will be talking about
offline reinforcement learning
which i'll distinguish from the online
case in the online case you get to
interact with the environment
as a
so you can change the policy and you can
explore the environment so in some sense
it's a
easier problem because you have greater
control
instead i'll work today in the offline
setting in the offline setting what you
observe is just a data set
of quadruples it's like
you have a state action
uh the next state and the reward
okay so you can just think of it this as
like statistics you're going to get a
data set of these quadruples and the
goal is to try
and extract the best possible policy you
can given these quadruples
so there's no inter no further
interaction with the environment beyond
your data set so truly this is a
statistics problem there's no uh you
know
online learning aspect
uh so the difficulty in most of rl these
days that we look at is the state space
is too large
uh
so
like for example in mario there's
something like you know 256 to a power
of 256 times 400 go is similarly big
something like 10 to the 700
so the state space is huge
super mario is harder
at least by this county yeah
i stole this from simon so if it's you
know
blame him if actually mario is easier
i think it is easier right can super
mario yeah
yeah
okay so
uh surely you know rl should have been
solved
when the state is not so big so let's
look at the best bound for offline rl
when this uh when the states in the
tabular case that is uh you're just
something like linear in the states
times some horizon factors
and some distribution shift factors i'll
talk about in a second
but you know i went in mathematically
and computed this it's bad you can see
this is 112 for the output uh this is
truly numbers like you know
these are numbers it's got a lot of
digits
uh yeah
okay
so you know just the number of states is
astronomical forget like whatever it is
number of particles in the universe
we're talking like
way bigger than that
okay so of course the way to address
this in practice to address every
practical problem is deep learning deep
learning solves everything
uh so what you do is function
approximation
so in supervised learning what we do is
that's supposed to be a cat that's a
terrible image
so then you try to learn
a function that distinguishes cats from
dogs again these are the images are very
high dimensional space
but a deep network can do this
with a very few relatively few number of
samples it doesn't need to see you know
every image
because it's somehow
finding some latent structure in the
space of images that distinguishes cats
and dogs so this can be linear kernel
and of course deep networks
and roughly speaking what you should
expect here is some bound like the
number of samples you need
is the cardinality the log of the
cardinality over epsilon squared
where epsilon is the desired accuracy
and this is simply you just have images
instead of states
and you know this is what you would like
for reinforcement learning also right
you would like that if the q function or
the value function
was truly in this class capital f then
you have sample complexity something
like log f over epsilon squared this is
sort of the dream of
rl
with function approximation
and this is in this does work in
practice people approximate q functions
value functions models they all kind of
work
so let's turn to look at the online rl
theory
the in fact there's a huge slew of
negative results everything's hard it's
ridiculous like something like you know
q star is linear this is hard even when
you add some gap assumptions so it's
like
not only is it linear but the second
best is much worse than the first pass
it's also hard
uh
something like when the cube functions a
single relu that's also hard
and then the positive results are kind
of uh
pathetic compared to the hardness uh so
this bilinear classes that we worked on
with simon here
is essentially the broadest class that
which we know how to do online rl but
almost all of these positive results the
name is bilinear
and hidden in there is like sort of
identifies that everything we can do
online rl has some sort of linear
structure underlying it maybe it's not
the q functions linear but something
else in it it's essentially you can
estimate the bellman error at least an
upper bound of it in a linear fashion
and then all of the arguments go through
this elliptic potential level so all the
things you hear about general function
approximation eluder dimension
bilinear whatever they are they're all
kind of linear essentially so online ro
is very very hard so then when we
finished this last year
i thought okay this is very bad or you
can even in the online study you can
only do
uh things that are essentially linear
nothing close to supervised learning
where like essentially you only care
about covering numbers
or some uh there's no other structural
property beyond covering
numbers then i thought okay
statistically hard there's like um like
for example this linear function
uh it says something like you can have a
family of mdps where the q star is
linear
but you need something like two to the h
interactions
or two to the h or two to the d yeah so
yeah
machine learning you only need to like
okay
covering numbers in our and
yeah roughly you know a caricature isn't
you know in standard statistical
learning erm or something i only need
covering numbers right yeah let's think
finite hypothesis has to be similar yeah
and there's i'm ignoring computation
only statistics and you may hope for
something like that in aura but but it's
not the case
and this bilinear for example is much
much stronger with things
so essentially what that means is maybe
this is impossible like there's no way
to get this like log q class or value
class over epsilon squared
okay uh then i thought okay
you know maybe i thought about this a
little bit and then i i was very naive i
thought okay online rl is hard and you
get to interact with the environment
right so then offline should only be
harder because you get less access
uh
so then i went to work on some simulator
settings where this is an easier model
where you get the query
like you get the query like essay you
don't need to like get to essay you can
directly just query sa and then cs prime
and reward this setting is easier and
you can do some things about
neural networks
uh then i realized that
it's not actually harder and to and this
is actually a trivial observation let's
look first at transfer learning
so offline rl is very similar to
transfer learning because the data set
you collect is from some behavior policy
that is not the optimal policy so you
can think uh the source is the offline
data set the target
is the data from the optimal policy
and for example again turning to
statistical learning as motivation
if you look at kernel methods you
there's a lot of results of this form
that the min max rate is some
distribution ratio b star over n to the
power of c so c is whatever exponent
kernel method gets when you have no
distribution shift like you know like
the non-parametric rates
uh the more interesting thing here is
this b star which is just simply the
soup norm of these ratios
and this is the best you can hope for in
transfer learning
and then so an offline it's a very
similar situation
uh what you can actually hope for is
this b star log f
poly in the horizon or discount and poly
in the epsilon
and this uh and this is easier than
online rl online rl is all about
avoiding this right this the two to the
d or two to the h i said is all this
distribution ratio it's like you have
one reward at the end of this tree and
you can't find it
and that's hidden in here and in offline
there's no way to get rid of this
anyways or just they live with it you
aim lower
and the problem may become tractable at
least
okay so our goal for today is to aim for
something of this type
um
target and source definition of this
star later on
uh
i'll explain what it is in the rl
setting for transfer learning this is
the only slide i have
okay so let's define my notation i'll
use more formally
i have an mdp of course an offline data
set and then my assays are drawn from
the data distribution
and then
reward and s prime so
this guy is unknown uh frequently we'll
just pretend it comes from a behavior
policy like the data set was actually
collected using a behavior policy
and there's also a start distribution
mu zero so you can access samples from
these two guys
so your data comes from u0 and uh the
start distribution
and one very important distribution is
this occupancy or discounted state
visitation under policy pi this is like
you play pi
forever and it's this uh it's like where
you end up when you play pi
well up to discounting
and then q pi and v pi the q function
and value function
okay
so sorry to define d by a are you
sampling the starting state from you not
or or or like
your policy encodes the starting
so keep trying to define
you start out
uh what is the starting state for d5 uh
news era museum so that doesn't change
between like your data or like i guess
your data set is arbitrary ssna so it
could be arbitrary like smash or yeah
arbor from uh
ddd
so then the first thing we can ask is
what should f approximate right like
okay in supervised learning is clear you
approximate the conditional mean
or the probability of y given x
um in offline rl what most the most
common thing people try
is uh the q q q q or value function
approximation
uh so let's look at what this
question will boil down to
is
you would want some density ratio
log f
uh so this density ratio you should
think of as
the d pi star
divided by
uh the data distribution the occupancy
of your data versus the occupancy of the
optimal
and i'll go over a lot of the definition
of this is different in many reasons log
f one over epsilon one over
one minus gamma
now this is what you should kind of hope
for
uh
least very very recently
um
this has been shown to be impossible
by something like
you can have there's a family of mdps
with a very small number of actions
the distribution shift is very small
there's only two cube functions
and you need at least s to one third
samples to get some constant accuracy
so basically they showed that
if the only assumption you have is that
the q star is in the family this is
still hard
so this is kind of analogous to i said
in the online case
linear function approximation is hard
for q here it's that uh it's not linear
there's just two things but you is you
have trouble deciding which two
and this b star
it even holds under stronger assumptions
of b star and i'll i'll go over what
these stronger assumptions are in a
second
so the point here made by these guys is
that
uh you know somehow value function
approximation is not enough
okay so let's see how to proceed
of course a lower bound shouldn't ever
discourage you the whole point is to
circumvent lower bounds
and the literature in fact already does
have many assumptions that circumvent
lower bounds
uh and i'll talk about the two i'll
focus on that are the most common are
called completeness and concentrability
which is another word for these
distribution ratios
so let's first go over what completeness
is
so
completeness
is a
um
completeness says that if you take the
bellman update the bellman backup
operator you stay in the function class
okay so it's kind of a notion of like of
like
i don't have very good intuition for
this but it's sort of what happens is
that it prevents an error propagation if
every time you stay in the function
class however it's it's not very
desirable as an assumption if you look
at it because
the key of sort of agnostic learning is
that when you use more expressive
function classes you reduce your
approximation error
here
if you when you measure approximation
error by violation of completeness like
f minus tf and how far is that from big
f
uh by adding things to f you can violate
it more because now you need to be
complete also for this additional
function like you can't do something
like okay i take f
i apply bowman to it now tf i add pf
into my function class but now t squared
f needs to be in it and so forth so what
you could end up happening is that
you can't sort of just satisfy this
assumption by being
by using bigger function classes
and there's also some empirical work
that what they did is they use
self-supervised learning or pre-trained
representations
actually not so it was supervised
representation learning they used
pre-trained representations
uh and they showed empirically that you
fail terribly although you're realizable
but you're not complete
okay and so
um a common justification for why
completeness is sort of acceptable
is that
uh it's frequently argued neural nets
and kernel methods are universal so then
you have to be complete right
this you know sounds correct but then if
you think about it for 20 seconds this
is terribly wrong
because
you need to use function classes of
bounded capacity in some sense either
rkhs norm balls or finite capacity
networks
and these bellman operators there's no
reason that you can preserve the
complexity even for linear functions you
can grow the norm of the parameter for
example
so kind of
uh these are not closed in the sense of
if you take
uh
you can universal approximator means
that you can increase the capacity so it
can eventually approximate everything
but like
the quantifiers is all wrong here sort
of what you need for completeness is
that a single function class
approximates all development backups
okay so a bellman operator may not
preserve the boundary complexity and
it's hard to design a function class to
do this because the bellman operator t
depends on the model
so sort of you know the whole point of
doing value function approximation is
the model free setting
if you knew the model you could enforce
completeness but without knowing it you
don't know
like it should really be t
subscript p
applied to f
uh and then you don't know which
functions to add because you don't know
the model that's kind of the fundamental
difficulty
uh that being said there are many
algorithms that can occur with pessimism
that work very well the classical one
sorry with completeness that works very
well the classical one is
f2i fitted two iteration
and there are some variants like mini
max fitted q iteration
and what these guys can do is they can
get something like what i said b star
log
f
over
sum epsilon pi 4 or something
they can guess something like this but
uh what their assumption is that
is something like you need
f minus tf to essentially sorry
you need
tf to be essentially nf
for all f
and you can be tolerant to approximation
error
violating completeness
but uh
but then violating completeness itself
is not monotone and expressiveness of
the function class which is sort of a
big problem
okay and the more recent one is fellman
consistent pessimism which improves this
number here so there's many definitions
that are very confusing i'll review
those in a minute
okay so these are sort of the three ways
people measure
a
distribution shift that is common in rl
the first one is kind of the best one
it's the data distribution un divided by
the optimal so this is like kind of the
analog of p target divided by p source
and transfer line
you would like to depend on this and
that's what pessimism buys you
but this one is much stronger already it
says that your data distribution needs
to cover
all d pi regardless of if it's optimal
or not that's already quite funny
because that's a very big space
potentially
and then there's a very very very strong
one which is sort of like a single step
this is like you know you run it for
many stuff so there's
this is like a single step version like
you need to cover it for every
transition for all essay and just one
step you need to cover this
there's a s missing here
so under the super strong version there
is a positive result
so they have something like
under the super strong distribution
ratio
and i missed a log s here
you can get polynomial sample complexity
in everything you care about the only
issue is that you need this super strong
distribution ratio
and the only example we know where it
can be made to help like there exists a
data distribution to make it hold is
when the transitions
are have low non-negative rank
which is a pretty strong assumption like
the transition is factorized and then
you can choose the data distribution to
be like the average of the rows of one
of the factors
okay and that's clearly much stronger
than say something like this
which just says you know wherever the
the best thing is you just need some
master to see it so is there super
strong definition
that's the transitions it's like p s
prime
i have a typo here
this is
i believe i see this is the marginal
this is like s prime and this is s prime
this is the marginal of the data density
and it needs to hold for all essay
right
that means that
your
coverage
so like this is like everything is
connected in the state space kind of
i mean
yeah you basically need that yeah you
basically need
like for like let's look at one essay
wherever it goes
you have to access
the same yeah you have to like it's like
every essay is almost the same
yeah it's a very
weird message
this is a completely non-standard not
very
fairly non-standard
it's kind of like you have access to
everything
yeah from every essay you can access
almost everything okay
yeah it's yeah it's rough
uh okay
yeah okay so the known example is when
you have
a non-negative rank and you choose the
data distribution
is the average of the notice
okay so compare this to transfer
learning which is the case we would kind
of
well we know how to do at least in a
rough sense
is you want to get this direction this d
pi star over d
or target over source
so at least in transfer learning that
one
is easy essentially trivial to get upper
bounds and for kernel methods there's no
lower bounds
but the way that people have recently
figured out how to do this for very
special models for example linear mdps
is using a technique called pessimism
that prevents so sort of a it's sort of
among all policies
uh that are covered you choose sort of
the worst case and this prevents some
sort of overestimation
uh and this method is very good it
allows you for example to do
general function classes under
completeness but lets you pay only this
good density ratio this b star
so either so the state of the field
right now is that all the known
algorithms
that allow these weaker
concentrabilities
the ones we kind of prefer the single
point or the all policy they require
completeness
so like fqi fitted q iteration and this
bellman pessimism
and similarly linear mdp satisfy
completeness
so
our goal today
is to try and aim for
to get this single point density ratio
and to get rid of completeness
okay cool
okay and it turns out our approach is
very very simple
uh let me start out with the dual lp
so this is sort of uh
this is the dual lp that solves for the
optimal state action occupancy
these constraints are known as the
bellman flow constraints and what they
make sure is that this d corresponds
with a policy
okay and it's a linear program
linear programs are good we have duality
so let's write it in primal dual form
uh
so sort of this is also fairly standard
for example in the textbook by pruderman
now i introduce the dual variable
the value function
and so then
optimality what i get back is the value
function and the optimal occupancy and
the optimal value
and then i just solve this lp that's not
lp this mid max it's a convex sorry
concave convex
and this is used in practice for example
that these dice style algorithms use
this
and this bi-linear pi learning
is sort of a standard approach
in designing an algorithm design for
mdps
okay let's make it more suitable for
offline setting
we're just going to a change of
variables
uh we don't you know we don't have
access to this right but we do have
access is to the data distribution so i
just took that
and i plug in w everywhere
uh so what i get out is this guy this
guy is just oh sorry this e i forgot to
define this e is always this thing here
it's just how much it's like how much
you violate the constraints
these are the things that are enforced
that you're a valid occupancy
okay the good thing here now is i can
compute this guy from samples now
where is double your new objective
uh sorry where is the oh sorry it's in
this e
oh well let's
sorry that's
yeah this is still convex concave
because the change of variables didn't
anymore
it was just the data distribution
the good thing now is this is now
computable by samples
you can check it's essentially it's
unbiased for the primal dual
like it's an unbiased estimator of the
prime multiple
uh
there are some problems here though
we have a counter example in the paper
we have a counter example in the paper
that basically shows that because this
is not strongly concave in w
but nature can sort of
force you to make errors because if you
commit to like a certain
you know tie breaking rule then nature
can always be adversarial to your tie
breaking rule to force you to make
mistakes so this by itself does not
quite work here
and the issue is it's not unique
essentially when you have a lot you have
poor coverage you have a lot of zeros
and there's places you don't see
and then you're not sure what the w like
the w can be many things
uh luckily
there's a simple way to fix this
so the simple way to fix this is
something these dice people already
figured out called density
regularization
uh
their motivation was not introducing
strong concavity but the way i'll
motivate it is
introducing strong concavity just think
of this as the square function for now
so i'm just is this is just a simple way
to make the problem strongly concave and
convex
in the optimizer of this concave convex
thing
i'll denote v star alpha w star alpha
the alpha is the regularization
parameter
uh though so the traditional
interpretation of this is from density
regularization
is that in these practical dice paper
what they say is i want to maximize the
reward
but i want to make sure i stay close to
the data distribution because like
uh you know if you're doing offline rl
and you leave the data distribution that
seems bad because you have no idea what
happens
and they would say okay i'm just going
to choose an f divergence
and that's exactly the same thing if you
take this die and write in primal dual
form you get back my regularized lp so
this is just sort of two different
interpretations
but for the purpose of my talk
is really to introduce
strong concavity and uniqueness
so given an occupancy it's easy to
extract the policy
you just choose you know this is just
the policy you just renormalize
essentially
okay so
our algorithm
is going to be very simple we're going
to solve the regularized lp
uh
ah the w is back good uh i solve the
regularized lp
i and then i
take at the density ratio
and then i extract the policy
but extracting the policy is not
the if you know pi d is very easy
and for the talk i'll assume i know pyd
when you don't know pi d in the paper we
have a behavior cloning procedure like a
way like imitation learning
that can extract it with some guarantees
but for now i'll just assume that you
can you know paid you know the
behavioral policy
so the extraction is easy
okay so now i got back pi hat
okay
so what assumptions do i need to analyze
this primal dual
thing this primal dual lp are not our
peanuts
it's curved it's strongly concave
regularize lp
is it linear
it's
linear i mean convex but linear
[Music]
because the policy extraction is all
done from the doubling
uh so the assumptions i'll need is that
uh
i will have
the single point concentrability but
it's on d star alpha it's on
the solution to the regularized lp
divided by the data distribution needs
to be covered
and the realizability now is also with
respect to
these regularized solutions
and notice i have two function classes
now
i have one function class for the value
function that's pretty standard and i
have another one for the importance
weights this density ratio like in
marginalized important sampling i would
have this
so i have two realizabilities
no which is sort of how i'm
circumventing the lower bound i talked
about when you only had the cube being
realizable
uh the f you need some properties about
boundedness and strongly convex not very
important the square function is
sufficient
and you need the function class is sort
of to be bounded this makes sense this
is actually in fact just this number
here it needs to be bounded and the v
function you can show is just
uh just because from an mvp property it
just blows up by a one over horizon
factor
so we'll also enforce the v function as
a bounded class because we know in mdps
this is the case
okay
so
the key here is that we do get away with
just realizability and this
concentrability here
and i'll define this as the statistical
error term this is the result of doing
uniform convergence on the primal dual
objective
the dot the more important term is just
this one here you just have log
of the function classes over n
the usual rate
okay so that's characterizing this is
just some simple bernstein in quality
type thing on this uh the sample versus
the population primal
uh so the first theorem is that the
policy we get
is something like that epsilon stat
divided by alpha and the strong
convexity parameter
and this is competing with pi star alpha
not the optimal is the regularized
optimal for now
okay so if you plug in the square
function what you find is your sample
complexity is something like
a bunch of some boundaries stuff
times 1 over epsilon to the 4 over here
and then but you actually really want to
compete with pi star 0 right the real
optimize policy
and you can do this this is easy you
just set alpha small and there's some
continuity or smoothness here
happening and it costs you in the rate
so you just set alpha small enough
and now your rate degrades a little bit
from epsilon 4 to epsilon 6 times
the size of the classes
but the good thing is you're actually
getting the optimal policy
so this does get you efficient learning
with single policy concentrability and
realizability
uh here's a comparison against
existing methods the first two
these are classical more classical
methods like fqi essentially
notice that you need conditions like for
all f you need something to be true
instead of just f star
uh this is the paper that has the super
strong concept probability but it only
needs q star enough
these are the more recent papers using
pessimism also for all f completeness
and this one also needs for all pi the q
pi is enough so like a policy
completeness like not just q star but
then on the density ratio they only need
realizability so this is like an
important sampling method
and our this is our algorithm
i didn't talk about this last row
these are the ones i talked about today
is that when you set alpha small you can
compete against a regularized one or
this one
and you only need various
realizabilities
what is the difference
[Music]
uh
this is like
uh this is like uh the baumann when you
fix the policy pie
like there's no uh like
it's like
yeah you need it for all pi it's like
bellman what's it called evaluation
it's a evaluation
the second one is
the last row okay the last row is like
if you really wanted the realizabilities
with respect to zero we have a result
that's much weaker
um like you can object here that okay
i'm assuming realizability has some
weird things right they're not like
fundamental to the problem in some sense
uh but this is a much weaker result
because you need this very weird
assumption
this is notice the inequalities
backwards
it's saying you know you need to
you're saying that
it needs a lower bound on this so this
is i
they call this sometimes ergodicity in
the literature
uh i have trouble interpreting it
personally
and so i'm i'm i personally like these
more i'm fine assuming realizability of
a weird thing
because you know as long as you make it
you you get to the i guess you don't
know what the ground truth is anyway
right you're just going to throw that
neural net at it make it big
and then it's monotone in the size of
the net and that's good enough for me
right how much time do i have
five minutes okay
the proof is actually very very simple
uh sort of the basic idea is that
you have function space which is like rs
by rsa
this is the occupancy measure this is
the um the value function
if you can restrict to classes and as
long as they contain the optimum
you're still the min max the max min
point
so this is like
there's nothing magic here it's just
saying that you take subsets of th you
take function you take like all space
tabular space you restrict to subsets of
the tabular
as long as i contain the optimum points
they're still maximum points or minimax
points
yeah
okay so the given that the proof is very
easy the first step is just huffing
you're on bias you do burn bernstein or
hufting
the second step is that
it's sort of like how you analyze erm
you add and subtract some stuff and then
you can bound the w hat versus the w
star alpha
okay and it's like twice the epsilon
stat this is just like you know uniform
concentration then you prove the erm is
within like twice the uniform
concentration
uh and then given that the strong
concavity gives you a bound on the the
density ratio
and then
this is all just perturbation now you
bound the density ratio the policies are
a function of the density ratio
and turns out if you do the algebra it's
a factor of two away
and then you use the performance
difference lemma to show that your
policy is near optimal then so is your
um
your value functions
okay and that's essentially the entire
proof there's there's it's really simple
um the other results on the paper that i
didn't have time to cover the first one
is
which i think are kind of important is
you can do
realizable itself is not that
interesting why erm is impressive is it
can do agnostic learning
this algorithm also has the property you
can do agnostic learning in two
different senses the first sentence is
that if the v and w are misspecified
you do as well as the best v and w in
your class
so there's you can define an
approximation error which is just you
know how far off
the min max value of the
vw in the class versus
the ground truth is
the second one also very important is
that sometimes the data coverages is
just bad
in this case you want to compete with
the best policy that you cover so
basically
perhaps like w star infinity norm is
huge the density ratio is huge but
you're saying well no i don't want to
compute with the one that has hits 10
million i'm just going to force myself
to compete with the one that density
ratio is 100. you can do that
so you're kind of agnostic to
also the coverage of the data set
and then the other things i skipped is
some behavior cloning algorithm
that allows you to do policy extraction
when you don't know behavior policy
uh there and then there's some stronger
improved sample complexity like here i
gave an epsilon six one
we also have one
asymptotically you can get back to like
epsilon 4.
but
it's something i don't really understand
something very weird about
if you have a regularized lp
there's some finite regularization
parameter where the solution is actually
exactly equal to the lp like usually you
expect
that you know you're some distance away
right because you perturb but
in lp like because it's linear i guess
you snap back to solution for small
enough regularization
and using that you can improve the
sample complexity but it's a pretty
asymptotic thing
so i guess my concluding thought here is
just sort of the primal dual formulation
it seems to me
it's the analog of erm for offline rl
uh
like meaning it can sort of do all of
these agnostic things it only needs
realizability it's robust approximation
ratio so forth
some things we've left
epsilon i'm not sure the optimal episode
dependency
um and right now to get good apps on
dependence we do need some
asymptotics things and perhaps for games
this is doable too i'm not sure because
i don't
think there's a min max for markov games
right i feel like it's not an lp maybe
it's complementarity or something
yeah
there is for markov games
but is there like i want one that looks
like value and occupancy
i feel like there should be
another one yeah because
then you have d pi and mu between
yeah
uh yeah that's all i have
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much are there any
questions in the room or online
by the way i'm monitoring the online
questions so if you are online and you
have questions please write them
any questions in the room
no
um for the uh agnostic results if your
approximation area is epsilon do you get
scaling with like one times epsilon or
some larger parameter times epsilon in
the bound uh
it's not an optimal constant okay yeah
it's not enough it's not yeah it's not
an optimal cause
it's
because it gets multiplied by the strong
concavity stuff
i guess that's why yeah
it might even be like square root
epsilon if i think about it more
carefully
i was just wondering how does the
structure of your reward function play a
role in the bounds for example if you
have a sparser reward so you have a lot
of zeroes and then you have like some
spike
so how
does this translate into some of the
bonds or
no none of this this is all sort of
under
the most vanilla
r is bounded by one setting
like
i know in some there's like variance
what is it called variance aware
where like when the reward is
simon knows this better than me for the
online setting they've done this
i don't know
also the transitions yeah
all right so let's take let's thank
jason again
[Applause]
uh
so we have a tea so uh
outside so there's the uh
daily uh tea time for simon's institute
so
that's an opportunity to also see other
visitors long-term visitors of the
causality program
so see you
again at
3 15.